under President Xi's role the Chinese
Communist Party is heading even faster
and further in the wrong direction more
internal repression more predatory
economic practices more heavy handedness
and most concerning for me a more
aggressive military posture it is
essential that we as an international
community wake up to the challenges
presented by China's manipulation of the
long-standing international rules based
order that has benefited all of us for
many decades covering the conference for
us from Munich is general well the
world's two most powerful nations
squared off against one another here in
Munich first the United States Secretary
of State Mike Pompeo and defense
secretary mark Esper giving notice
firing the starting gun essentially on
what could be a new era of US defence
and foreign policy China as enemy number
one the Pentagon's
top priority said mark Esper because of
its more aggressive military posturing
in the region it's trade economic and
territorial ambitions further afield he
said we do not want conflict with China
we want China to play by the rules abide
by international norms in short we want
China to behave and making the point in
no uncertain terms that the u.s. expects
its allies to view things likewise
noting in particular Chinese telecom
giant Huawei some European allies the UK
in particular in talks with Huawei to
help build their 5g networks well the
u.s. of course seasoned far away as a
Trojan horse for Chinese intelligence
well it wasn't long before China had the
opportunity here to respond Wang Yi the
Foreign Minister saying China will not
follow the Western model and seek
hegemony in the world but rather choose
a policy of peaceful development working
for shared prosperity and he had this
very pointed response to those US
comments before I came here my
colleagues told me about what the two
Americans senior officials said and they
have been once again repeating their
smears and criticism of China it has
become a common scenario they basically
say the same thing wherever they go
about China and I don't want to waste
our time respond
to each and everything they've said what
I want to say is that all of these
accusations against China are lies they
are not based on facts
so China emerging here presenting itself
certainly as an unlikely standard bearer
for multilateralism the very policy
plank and pillar upon which Western
diplomacy has been built and practiced
for decades and the very thing that many
here and elsewhere would say that the
Trump administration has abandoned so
here's my own Bashara our senior
political analyst in London to talk
through some of us well and the fact
that Mark Esper said this in Munich
Jonah described it earlier is a platform
really for people to say what they want
but he said that in Munich in Europe
there's a very specific audience here
isn't there absolutely and I think the
statements should not be read seen or
understood outside this context that
this is directed to Europe
not even to China per se or to the US
public to the American public because
there's nothing that we've heard knew
from the from administration about what
sort of a strategy are they envisioning
a new strategy to deal with China
because we all know that they've
abandoned the strategy of the previous
president President Obama's pivot to
Asia and the trans-pacific partnership
that was abandoned by the Trump
administration two strategies that were
meant to contain China militarily and
economically so what we hear here today
is basically also similar to what we
heard from the Obama administration that
China while it should be underwriting
the international order with the United
States has been undermining it and
that's why the Trump administration is
upping the ante but where and who well
it's towards Europe because it wants
Europe to get with the program and get
behind the United States and it comes to
why we are it comes to anything else the
United States feels that Europe must
support the United States but what we've
heard from other speakers like President
macron
the German president is that there's a
sense in Europe that the United States
or rather the Trump administration has
been taking it for a ride been taken
advantage of it and that Europe needs to
speak more United independently of the
United States including on question of
China and whether or not to incorporate
Huawei in its technology or artificial
intelligence or what-have-you
so we have a bit of nuance a bit of I
would say disagreement between Europe
and the United States on this issue